No.
What are they paying for?
You're paying for that fun
that's associated with the
anticipation of the reward
and the brain.
You know,
your,
your emotional brain isn't that
great at calculating mathematically
probabilities.
And so it sort of says some chance you
have some chance of winning $50 million.
Well,
it might be one in 380 million,
but your,
you know,
your anticipation system
isn't a mathematical system.
It just says,
well,
you have some chance that's
a lot more than none.
Well,
in some ways it's infinitely more than
none because at zero you have no chance.
And you know,
with one tech you have some chance.
So that gets the old excitement going.